[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
hello and welcome everyone to play the
people the December edition is what
we're going to going to call it for no
reason whatsoever
and is it December it is already awesome
brace disturbing bit of news I learned
today so happy winter time everyone and
we'll be we'll be doing this for about
an hour and a half I suppose since
there's two of us we will try to combine
our unmatched wisdom and things into we
were told to introduce ourselves
yes I'm Grandmaster Peter Svidler and
with me is must've gained numerous
mishchenko and we're here to the
commentary work so we're we're not
pretty chess players and please don't
judge us too harshly
so this yeah just a brief introduction I
already have I see 23 challenges there
and 24 as I speak we will not be playing
any bullet because we're old men and we
can't play bullet there will be some
pendant brain action at some point and
we prefer rated challenges to unrated
because we were told we need to get this
accounts rating to 2500 so which seems
to be challenging yeah it's one and a
half hours
it doesn't sound realistic but who knows
I don't know what the rating is
currently so you can look at the data
this game where we just flagged
seemingly having no beliefs no pieces
whatsoever yeah you can that's a bullet
game so oh yeah that's different
no scrolling scrolling is always a
mistake so I do see one rated challenge
at least one there's a number of rated
okay so let's go so we are rated 2003
and I tried to play with my key no you
do it on a second movie I did the bomb
cloud the bomb Club might actually I
mean might appear an hour and a half is
maybe too short a time too
to attempt on clout properly but uh what
was that I have no idea what D for D for
was they well maybe it's still not too
late now you fight for the center that's
what we were okay okay i confuse what is
this center that you speak of but sort
of in in more general terms this is
obviously a very you know heavily
theoretically discussed position I have
no idea what I'm doing with the white
pieces here I also have no idea what I
would be doing here with the black
pieces but that's my normal state of
eternal confuse a five yeah I think now
in particular you're supposed to go for
these sharp lines with the Bishop g5
because once once we get our Bishop to
this horrible g3 square we will have
ideas of playing 93 and 95 and this is
supposed to be for some reason very good
he's spinning our horse yeah look at our
force yeah and it's going to be very
pinned and also be smelling of raisins I
don't know about h3 but I think the idea
is if he plays Bishop h5g for might be
very that's yeah that's probably what we
do because then it's very difficult for
black to unpin himself properly so this
is this is what I will be attempting and
now it's it takes a very very long time
for black no-clean I think might be to
do here is the question
what are you gonna need three but yeah
yeah it's like a 3 C 2 e 3 but might be
too long of a distance right we can do
this we can go 92 and rook e1 in light
of 193 night there 5 plans because now
with the bishop on e6 it really is very
very slow for black it's very difficult
night BT 2 and press the button yeah
maybe maybe just play the normal
movement press the button yeah no my
Sabra see how like I supposed to get
yeah I think I think h5 is not the
answer though I'm pretty sure h5 kind of
plays into our way the night HD looks
kind of interesting because also just
ignore it I guess I see Queen d7 is the
idea yeah that that were he wants yes oh
yeah we should probably do something
about that king h1 with the idea of
playing on the G file later is look can
we can we play I mean I'm not
a police denied donation can we play
Bishop g5 night eh for me just to make
it weird
yeah there was there was something I
also thought about but then he takes and
after night - when he goes Bishop h5 I
suppose but we win the piece right let's
try this
how does he take a JUnit h4 are you want
to take on yeah I just wanted to taste V
AG Queen d7 99 teach for that's a very
good point yeah the point is after takes
takes Queen d7 we can play Knight H for
protecting the pawn on g4 with the Queen
and also attacking the bishop on g6
which is very relevant in that position
and yeah if the way that she lands only
five if if that goes there we will be
doing a reasonably fine yeah quite well
and I mean the biggest takeaway so far
from this game is that the bishop
doesn't really belong on g6 and it's
much better to force white into into all
of these problems by playing g5 as early
as possible if you allow Bishop g5 in
the joka pianos these days you are more
or less obliged to go age 65 and just
play those very very sharp positions
that arise yeah well what we gonna be
doing yeah precisely in this do we do
winter cup of one good thing yeah
they're not really a couple uncle thing
is attractive but giving mate I think is
sort of more attractive but you can
combine by taking on a three going on f6
going Queen f3
yeah let's maybe let's maybe go this way
kingi taurua quechua me it feels like
the position should be good enough yeah
completely winning if we don't lose our
mind somewhere which is like you you
can't possible you comes really yeah and
then let's hide it entirely
overall this hey wait now he's gonna
play 98 96 night Shh we don't that was
there was a good plan and and definitely
better than G where were you when Roop
h1 or g1 let's put one on h1z1 let's be
spectacular I don't see any kind of yeah
the other one goes to g1 then King f1
and then you see yeah he goes Kings
you're jetting afraid those so we might
actually have to I found a very nice
trick there it doesn't work now I
thought I can play g5 here well if he
thanks with the rook in the end they
have a mission a g6 chamber you can take
with the born again I no longer another
fight why just don't go Kiki to night F
193 nobody I mean we eventually he will
but then we're gonna play Knight a file
the woman he goes to d8 yeah that's fair
yes fair and then I don't get to is our
one last port piece so we would very
much like to now we can we can we afford
to allow 96 probably not you know that
will be unpleasant and which one because
there is some argument for taking with
the e pawn it's actually less he's gonna
give us he sake hang on a second do we
start with the rocket shape to win the G
file it could be yeah and then we take
with the Jeep on yes well I'll go catch
two though and the king running is also
actually from I want to say that from
from a somewhat miss played opening our
opponent is defending really really well
here
and we're also done would it be that we
are not playing good yeah we're not
playing well but that's a given that's
not something that even needs to be
mentioned necessarily our opponent
playing well I think is it's it's good
to remark on honestly challenging at
first place
I want to go king debunking see to
pretend I'm King Lear and yd1 why not d2
because like us culture yes light
squares yeah yeah precisely but I wanted
this one I want to I want to be
pronounced yeah I want to pretend for
three seconds and I'm King Lear and and
I'm playing the most memorable game of
the tournament nobody's gonna believe me
though yeah but how do we win if I mean
yeah I mean what's going game I know
let's go before yeah yeah for at the
center still hanging is is kind of
annoying this so I want to go G for and
after mission b6 I'm not entirely sure
what I want to be honest I you want d5
you wait maybe now we actually play
Queen yourself yeah we play King g7
seems good and we pretend we've created
a threat
that's like it will be and the trick is
if you take stays occasionally we can
actually take one of seven in that
position I think but that might not be
great because you can just blinking
bieed them and the knight is hanging our
weight okay I agree I don't think we
even better here to be honest we are
Bishop of seven King be eight do you
need this one on and wait this is where
I would like this is where I should have
played team Giovanni - but I brought it
all the way to see - for no particular
reason take it to me five maybe so that
if he takes the knight we go is six I
cannot calculate like why are we why are
we reviving no sure it's not sure yeah
this is an increment right because we
are pretty long time
yeah we're not getting 2,500 today
people yeah but this much is clear by
this game it's you can quite safely say
that this is the one thing that is not
happening on this stream no 2,500 yeah I
don't know what what exactly is
happening on this stream but we're not
getting to 2,500 ah cool kingi - so I
found some kind of a restructuring which
also gives us nothing but it is well it
does well with the King on his 7 I still
really don't understand how we create a
single thread in this position we put
the bishop on c4 we go d5 at some point
we go before that's what I thought we
are knowing the guy till he's like
doesn't know what to do okay this see
some improvement in fortunes I'm pretty
sure this is this should not have been
played and then we put the with hope on
the others at least at least now I
understand where my pieces are going
yeah we had a we had a market
improvement in fortunes in the last
three moves market what the hell am I
saying and what is slightly better we
should fix of seven root K eight will at
some point be a very nice little tactic
I can and I will never make what do you
do I mean there was a beautiful Bishop
on d5 yeah but now I will win all the
forms all the point and winning all the
pawns has to has to be careful taking b6
now you can do it yeah
this has to count for yeah okay sue yeah
I don't know because once again it feels
like more or less anything wins here and
that's a very dangerous yeah state of
mind I've already said it once in this
game and was spectacular incorrect but I
think this time this time I'm safer in
my assumptions because I have extra
material yeah
don't blunder the rook think it'd be
fine I gave it track yes what I missed
yes yes I'll go forward this is this is
how you and this position how well we
could we're gonna flag him though we or
he will this is how it yeah it will end
up is yeah how grand monsters Wiener
chest by flagging there yeah by plugging
their opponents mercilessly he's upon
its running though yeah okay let it run
a seven was probably a good move there
but seven seconds stop talking yeah he
all he'll gonna flag us people are mean
on internet like we have a winning
position are faint yes you'd start
beaten was a challenging game excellent
start excellent that's exactly the word
we're looking for here excellent start
barely winning with one second on the
clock and watching a completely waiting
position we've already set a record
that's voices in my head well Ben Simon
you know then yet he said we just set
the record for all-time viewership on
played excellent and thanks so here I am
scrolling thanks to you my friend raises
all thanks to Benin yam whatever happens
on this show is fully credited to better
nobody else apologies for this
persistent cough that's and let me let
me say GG is the wild breath who
actually did play really well for long
stretches of that game let's play I mean
we don't have unlimited I mean you have
unlimited time because you'll be doing
another one of these our friend
absolutely but I don't
so let's play let's play more more chess
I'm looking for for what it's uh it's a
feel like maybe I shouldn't I'm looking
for some somewhat higher rated
challenges but why would you because I
want to win more rating hmm
I'm on the quest come on how things work
three-nil say so you can hear I have a
quest quest excel how much we want what
we want some yeah we want 10 points 10
points yes that's great can I please
take some side quests today I like this
main quest appears to be unworkable I'm
opting for side quests now wait a sec
what what what was that I do not know
93 g5 there was the theoretical move
along mister before maybe wasn't wasn't
ideal you can also even do this I've
seen come ski to the must again if I'm
slandering come ski apology
but I don't think I am I think I've seen
him I've seen him do this
see five and ninety six yeah yeah
developing someone I mean first you ruin
your position beyond beyond all the
potential for repair and recognize
what's there yeah and then beyond all
recognition of it you know it appears
that we are doing quite fine but there
is yeah you might prob I don't think I
don't think you're ever doing quite fine
in this opening in the Dutch yeah like
I've played the Dutch I'm never gonna be
doing quite fine and in the meantime I
assume for a priest the priest won the
game right
no not sure yeah that's her so we had we
had one job and we failed at it we were
going to support the United Kingdom and
now we don't know if our support counted
for for anything I'm trying to force
into taken six after which she will
still be better I don't know I don't
know if that's a sensible course of
action maybe we take with the Queen
oh why would you because I don't want to
allow 94 maybe seven yeah and I think we
have a 94 thing I think you guys to take
take the the force in the f6 book but
then what do we take with that we ever
take with the pawn there to push e5 as
early as possible no oh I mean consider
but there's okay 94 we are super happy
are we he goes maybe for no reason yeah
he goes see five trays the bishops often
we are actually worse I think
well we worried a Wars no matter what
you ever played the Dutch so we deserve
what we get but Quinby eight is there
any reason maybe took like they can see
for an ongoing 94 could be but if he
takes on f6 we will win at a point yeah
face take it take it like we have two
minutes Peter I'll speed up okay Bishop
f6 um community to appears to be quite
strong actually like but that's an
advanced concept now yeah that's I'm not
afraid of advanced concepts on on three
three no blades I mean even if someone
comes up with it that's a fair point
yeah
we'll agree with you here it's like yeah
once again the the game we are watching
as the you know as the site was the
hearthstone game I mean you do not play
around everything so you do not play
around two people taking on f6 going
Queen d2 instead of recapturing the pawn
yes we won their four point here and we
should be doing okay even though white
actually has very legitimate
compensation legitimate compensation for
an exchange you mean I could have taken
on c5 and yeah I don't I don't like I
mean I really don't like we don't like
exchange is being left with this is a
before horrible horrible thing on CAT I
would much rather pick this pawn up and
hope I will be able to push me 65 at
some point later in life and they yeah I
think he thinks we bring the bishop back
we play a five or four and then bringing
the bishop back to e3 or evenly three
yeah and it's a lot yeah I was kind of
expecting everybody will allow me a
three I could have played it on the
previous move actually if we go here
maybe just giving this intermediate kind
of Bishop III then take the bishop
reform yeah that could have been decent
but obviously I know I missed that and
completely or and then you just want to
be normal you want to go Bishop if this
were five four okay I know my next cuz a
loves a5 was as well I mean after he
went for B for every well now you can
because I suspect he's planning 96 so
that movie here five might be just a
terrible weakening weakening the poem
before in also getting rid of the
weakness on a6 for you know
quote-unquote
end games nobody believes and games
exist but well they do
yeah but they I was playing chess I mean
basically trying to they survive I don't
know if we need the old from there but
the guy still has reasonable
compensation yeah exactly like thinking
some queen g4 things I'm worried 24 in
some order is I'm worried like I was
hoping f3 will to the point that we
consider f3 know we don't know we
definitely consider a three I'm just
wondering if there is something stronger
but I quite like f3
if he takes mister page to check forces
him to go to if one but I don't sell to
exceed each one is possible ruk a one
it's not really one okay we are pulling
up in this and look at this we force the
endgame
I think if there is a correct choice
here to kind of tear things up mess
things up and also kind of force him to
you can take with the boom distract his
attention from giving us let me play a
move of some description with your
perceive root of 45 I today if you
create I mean I don't know if it works a
beautiful move it's kind of funny move
is looking for any good because I
currently don't see how it's refuted
Quinn geez I think we have a fake go for
it
well I suspect we kind of miss played
the whole thing but yeah that's that's
pretty obvious that it should have been
a cleaner a cleaner approach somewhere
when you 6-4 I still feel like we're
doing okay Rock d6 ah this is the
problem after he sees he'll be
threatening a perpetual I'll be afraid
of perpetual though what I mean we don't
want the professional we don't want a
perpetual we can play Queen f7 because
we're better we know 758 we are granted
play we can play Queen f7 yeah that was
a complete Queen Eason creating a third
of Queen III check and then maybe Queen
g5 check next move probably this is what
we do
I will flag him as usual or that yeah or
he goes Queenie a check and then our
task becomes significantly simpler
because we're just a piece up for not
very much check on h2 yeah that's a
that's a strong move here and we've won
another seven points only only 480 four
to go
easy easy seems to be easy no seriously
though we have some suspicious positions
yeah we had a very suspicious position
in this game but I mean 93 is a very
very decent reply against the Dutch so
that's highly that's highly surprising
whoops there was not something I needed
to do yeah well yeah just trying to
trying to pick challenges is is not my
strongest okay I was about to say why we
always playing white and we actually
played black in the previous game well
and let's remind people that
we do play the people but the main
purpose is that London classics thoughts
the more of the final fabulous tour so
they'll be there will be repeater doing
proper commentary I'll be doing Russian
commentary and it starts the show starts
10:00 to 10:00 local time and 10:00 to
4:00 p.m. London something else
something like that ready in confused
yeah we're not we're not great with with
time zones but that sounded about right
local time beings in st. Louis time of
course we are in st. Louis do you
remember what we're supposed to do here
is it play the a lopping with colors
reversed and they're stupid move g3
that's what we are supposed to do yeah I
don't think we like a apart from from us
being very proud we're a tempo how
commissioned Bishop g2 yeah let's not
listen yeah yeah takes we take with the
Queen well Castle would have been no no
that's too much
Queen d3 okay yeah I think now we're
kind of obliged to win the pawn back but
we're not entirely unhappy this looks
like a very very good Terrace for white
what would be it will be very dark I in
about the guy named turret he didn't
like the Knights being put on the edge
of the board right you got sayings yeah
he was he was like a sage have you seen
the trailer for the Spongebob movie Anna
not my thing
Keanu Reeves plays a sage who is also
sage or I mean a boost of sage you know
Jessa yeah it's a question that it's
well the biggest the biggest thing ever
like that's related question do we go
Knight f5 here I was kind of looking for
ways to win this porn Yuri yeah but that
that could be one hope yes I mean to
annoy the opponent for sure because what
he's doing now
I think used to take and play d4 perhaps
he has to castle and pretend that he
doesn't care about the pond g5 that
actually makes more sense to me because
if he causes if we take yeah zoo-wee
takes and then he goes yeah but that's
like Knight h6 something that that's not
the king or king a change whatever we
will find out
yeah we'll find out why resigning I mean
I could be life here I really want to
punish this somehow well you should but
what do we do yeah I completely missed
this movement it might be quite strong
actually because 97 how do we get rid of
all the air I mean until I make a move
there will be these horrible errors on
the board right I'm really not good with
yeah they should have switched them off
no no errors are important important for
yeah for whatever if we have four four
things arrows like I see anymore 97 is
my 17 afraid I don't wait what's the
draw Queen d4 you mean 2496 I think I go
to f4 g5 do we not lose a piece we go
back to f3 and I mean whatever the guy
starts playing g5
yeah we're not that unhappy about g5
that's that's true yeah that's true he
can also take on a fight and go back to
e6 and that might be playable though
after obi-wan he could still have issues
with the d5 yeah that seems to be like a
comfortable I salami I think he had to
try 96 in my position I'm pretty sure
there was a better option than this
because ya know that's pre move if he
castles what do we do before I think we
can take if I'm a g4 I yeah I'm very
configured before it's not the move
agreed to be six just just go good boy
good to get to good square yeah what a
good school the point I wanted to make
if he cancelled if he would have castle
I'm not sure if we're supposed to take
because like he trades everything girls
Bishop f6 very often they have but yeah
but I think I take I take not with
everything like I think with the rook at
the end and I don't be really allowed
bishop
there's before six even there yeah
that's a very good point actually
yeah but I think now we do think because
you'll have to spend the temple moving
the bitter side square no black seems to
be in trouble yeah how are feeling we're
doing about the other thing is now we
can actually play e2e for aya after Rico
so yeah that's that's very attractive
actually the castles castles e4 because
of the beam along the G file that he
created for himself
no we can't a quick emplacement man I
want to play for so he takes we go Queen
a for Jack 77
and not sure nothing I don't think it's
that great we can go this before Bishop
e5 before I think we take the pool yeah
there's no reason let's let's show yeah
I was just trying to embellish and
endgame scales did I don't have any well
you do well I have you so I have some no
it'll be three yeah you know you know
you know how this thing is done yeah we
can sort about it yeah that that wasn't
yeah actually be sick yeah a bit
annoying
yeah after v6 there would still be some
questions but this type of end games
typically you don't have a punani to and
you are still much better yeah like even
without the pollinate so I'd feel yeah
maybe not because Ruby g8r a yes but
from the Catalan a very often you have
this one like no II to opponents is Neil
White is practically winning and this
particular one rook h8 will is kind of
unlikely to participate that's there was
a nice move actually it also Stargate we
should be six but yeah that that porn we
care I mean I want to stop the room from
coming out but it will it will
eventually have it will eventually it
will eventually have a square its yeah
no let's let's see well play g4
nevertheless he goes h3 I was a bit
annoyed about that but probably I mean
that's okay h3 we put duty to ph4 I have
the peasants oh yeah but you go if dream
let's go you want to start because of
trees yeah that's maybe a good start
with a four I mean but like this is you
know the one way to create some
complications for yourself yeah well in
fact there's h5h forum Bell played moves
yeah I mean if he I mean we're still
we're still firmly in control here of
course but I think just ignoring the H
puzzles was maybe spoke memeing around
that that was a there was actually a
good sequence
Eva please for I didn't like I didn't
like Lee yeah I'm miss playing this
quite badly but I also at some point
felt like I needed to speed up I uh
you're right on this one let's not
blunder mate though yeah take more pawns
though and or what only five is annoying
I have actually played myself into into
some sort of well I don't know if it's
called if it's necessarily cool
seven first you know City where it goes
I think goes now if I know I can now we
are safe
yeah I think you got to go King D six to
have rugby five as an option because
this obviously gives us time to I don't
know why I'm forcing into play g5 I mean
it's not a bad move for him well well
well well well now finally let's do some
nice thing is yeah so you should f2 and
go to a rookin game yet alter yes yes I
win time though yeah we aren't we are in
time yeah yeah this this this water is a
sign of easier to yeah this is no longer
really a I mean we might get flag that's
a whole other subject but we have forty
seconds did to be eight yes precisely
yeah to stop any kind of fruit calf -
nonsense yeah you know it's just are
giving up material I mean I mean this is
Lucena this is enough I know we don't
need more we just need to play Ruka
faith yes need to play quickly here who
needs yeah Jesse that's Peters approach
I mean he feels guilty when he is like
two pawns up or something he need
precisely one and then to win like you
know toe-to-toe against at all no but
like here I don't need to think anymore
this is the advantage of we play with
incremented that was unfair like the
advantage of going for the Lucena is
that I no longer have to switch the
brain on okay yeah precisely in 13
points pogchamp you know 13 points
speaking of not needing a brain at some
point trying brain yeah so i'm gonna be
the the hand right I don't know you want
me to try to play chess that sounds that
sounds scary terrifying we can we can
try we can try for one probably
something with an intro oh well that's
preferable something with an increment
night I mean doesn't matter okay so we
kind of given out the information that
you can consider some weird-looking
image yeah II for the night night anyway
born okay
trying to justify my first move I mean
yes I see that that's what you should do
that that's a brilliant move Defoe I
think there's a number of moves that are
playable there yeah
only one of them being brilliant it's
default okay I'm not gonna argue with me
wall renowned special whoa night okay
I'm kind of pushing myself at the mercy
of the Queen thank you
Queen okay just for you this time it's a
queen yeah
there's anyone I mean there's there's
some famous videos on the topic like
bone apart from sort of normal hand and
brain there's also the sabotage hand and
brain which could be what I should not
do import it all here yeah that's why
you have to play with the bone okay
why they're still going to be doing fine
yep right
but what if he plays porn that's that's
my that's unfortunate that's my biggest
issue with this position is that yeah
I'm very confused about what are we
supposed to do here
oh we were not supposed to give him a
check but that's okay porn but I saw
check how could I give it yeah
Knight Queen uh-huh
you're confusing me there are no good
squares for the piece motive the world
too many choices right yes I should have
said the bishop yeah yeah bubble life
formation now we're even not entirely
equal in the same game and I think the
Sun game is already our almond our
opponent giving us some additional yeah
27 was really like yeah why do you trade
the I mean you have this beautiful
centralized Queen and you traded for the
one on this seven that seemed suboptimal
I think white with every kind of you
yeah well white white was much better
porn yeah I knew this one I knew this
one
whoa bishop no we're doing okay suddenly
mmm
might be more than okay might be more
than okay ya know that we deserve it but
this shirt
that was a trap though I'm pretty sure
he will now show to us why why the pawn
shouldn't be yeah well if I'm entirely
honest I was planning for Bishop after
Bishop
yeah Ruka 1 followed by before in that
position was actually a bit of a problem
so Castle probably yeah have to be four
yeah but then be 5 and no it was 85
Bishop d5 I mean deliver 25 is this
still kind of very solid a king I think
that's a king move yeah that's a king
move damn precisely that was that was
the point because cause otherwise I what
am I supposed to say like castle already
gives it away Rupe
that's maybe I will I would say the
bishop yeah maybe this our move I saw
flu sometime
arm it yes
whatever porn
yeah it's getting challenging I mean
like well I mean that minute left
yeah like it's a it's a very comfortable
conversion in general but it's a
conversion that takes time and yeah yeah
for this I'm cific game mode i yeah and
to be a bit normally this is no longer
really a challenging position to win but
ya have to be more focused rook get rid
of them I mean the more we trade the
less we blunder that's always been my
motto Brooke yeah I don't know why
Bishop taste it was played their route
days it was perfect perfectly fine and
yeah it's like this we could could have
taken on c5 first but yeah true dat
including routine is never a mistake
there bishop
look
Bishop III was calculating Bishop c1 for
some reason here we should differ even
stronger I was going to say that just be
five before an a3 is Bishop is very
strong but with a [ __ ] 25 we don't have
to
bishop to any move yep
so yeah that was the the the point that
he began he was making there that check
was a mistake is very valid because in
this position just plain Queen d6 I
suppose or Queen d6 or even to d8
yes some sort of well I didn't want to
allow the immediate before I thought
maybe of the Queen yeah well you know
thinking theta now that I think it could
be the Queen a5 is the move to be in the
deep bones are quite some time and then
you go c5 and the [ __ ] knight c6
because this has to be a theory of it
yeah the Queen d6 kind of what I did is
clearly wrong but what what what I did
was clearly a wrong way at the moment
when I played Queen d7 we really had a
problem in this game yeah so another
thing we could try
is it kind of like if the person who we
will pick actually will watch the next
20 seconds we are dead in the water but
our hope is that maybe he isn't
so we'll try the the the thing that was
done to me once
we cannot castle until our opponent
castles and we can only castle the
opposite the opposite side if you are
castling at all yeah we are not forced
to cuz we can keep the King inside yeah
we can keep it in the center but we are
not allowed to castle same same side
inside and we are not allowed to castle
before he yes and yeah always seconds so
yeah so what we do yeah I mean I have no
idea how to approach the openings--
openings that easier I can I can teach
you I think that's that's in that game
how do we prepare to castle both sides
g3 b3 and then he will be unable to
guess our third move okay I still want
to try with our sorry he's not with the
night belongs to you you could be three
G 3 d3
develop you know but that's that's kind
of that's very feeble that's in the
trope that's very feeble yeah we want to
be you know daring and bold and things
yeah all the things that we are and you
know we we want to pretend for now yeah
well what's wait sec it's it's kind of
even started you know people often say
issue a challenge and then go make it a
but so so what do we do yeah we'll give
him another I don't know 10 seconds and
then I will start searching for
for a boardgame button I found it
question is is Swit liberated swindler
is rated R R I mean over here yeah how
am I supposed to answer that question
you know I am a pirate because the
Pirates are free I don't yeah precisely
come on like I do have an account on my
chest but I'm not playing on it what
exactly is the time control you want
we've been asked we starting from sort
of 3-0 but like be kind to us 3-2 is
preferable to 3-0 because we don't like
losing on time and completely winning
positions or even completely losing
positions to bless that's fine yeah
I mean losing your time yeah so will
will will try once more to get this this
whole cussing thing going and if that
doesn't start as well we might just
abandon yeah okay abandoned so now oh
wait for he probably gonna console short
Isis yes so we start with dr. yeah I
suspect him of costly short we start
preparing here so we still is still one
d3 and III how would like how how would
the spiritual father of castling
queenside and every single opening
bother Joe Baba approach this he won't
play g3 at first yeah first of all g3 is
already a horrible misspellings okay I'm
you probably go III yeah I think we go
be 393 Queen e2 yeah I think that's
that's yeah well c6 makes her life
easier yeah 93 that's that's fine
yeah we're allowing like maybe we should
have started with Queenie sir that's
fine H is gonna give us a very natural
kind of lays it in no but he doesn't
castle yet ah that's annoying
ah you know what that's annoying Bishop
g2 but we're kind of safe yeah okay now
we still wait for a couple we can still
wait by making normal moves ran out of
fur fur for a couple more moves here
like Queen f3 Susan C d-four might not
be okay it's done should have played we
for yeah I don't know I don't like
killing off my
and now a nature move would be to castle
either side but we're kind of running
out of neck and it also does mean that
we are not allowed to move the works
right
also means that we're playing against
somebody who's heard us I'm pretty sure
yeah d2 d3 yeah okay that's me
let's make move more I wanted to go G
for more than commitment then we are
getting in castle oh yeah yeah where
would be really suspicious h5 so the
guys gonna prepare on the kingside and
then he's gonna cancel yeah so how do we
play around there Adri yeah very safe
and let's all forget we can keep a key
in the center yeah so at some point
let's trick him he's got a console and
we're gonna get King D - no I think I am
really sure if he castles we are I don't
I think it's unfair to keep the King in
the center if he castles unfair you me
we need 6 I'm gonna let B 1 D 2 a 3 a my
bad person now that's fine I mean I know
what I know the answer that question but
is this incorrect is yeah once again
let's put some it's got a disclaimer so
that's not the proper game of chess
that's ah ha ha God was there gotcha but
I guess he forced us to weaken our core
inside now
h5 is terrible from the edifice we're
gonna go g4 now
well yeah we're forecasting long no no
buster
I have a at first opportunity right yeah
I have a wee oh wee oh here it sake yeah
but like you take no I thought blocking
the entire thing is cool it's like you
go d4 and then I'm thanking beer I mean
either you have the time then or you you
do have the time anyway because King p1
is the move you always play I think like
we're I think we're significantly better
in an endgame there off the g4 but yeah
like someone said the end game I'm using
here I'm using swear words on the show
now and sign me up
yeah so easy angle let's go King do on
King be 1
yes let's make a waiting move for one
more move
before we establish you know I know I
know now I can sort of subscribe to you
and this is this is what I was hoping
for that yes super happy
G for gets provoked and then we can know
we are super happy for whatever reason
it is we're not exactly who's super
happy but we've won a couple of Duke c1
c4 or just c4 I don't know how it's
played now it's certain we have to play
only on the queenside
right even though we've cancelled or we
can go G for like a brave but thanks
goes a 596 I considered that now he's
faced with a knight actually before age
three or five nights oh yeah yeah I
don't think that's good I think we we
actually switch to play on the queenside
also we're down a minute
ah that's that's acceptable we're down a
minion and upper gold for those who
knows what it means
yeah so we're down a minute and upper
bishop papa bishop like yes currently
yes does he who doesn't do doesn't do
very much but we're bringing it back to
f1 and the question is if he captures on
c4 well with uh with great sadness we
will have to take with the night I guess
because a long night they for is
suspicious suspicious but or suspect
actually suspicious is something else
yeah
massive what kind of makes his place so
much easier just goes night md5 and
feels feels very good about himself
which is not something we want to allow
obviously this is not like we don't yeah
the show it's not about people feeling
good for themselves do we have a place C
five I don't think we do what do we do
continue making release we need to be
making and then will reconsider I think
eventually we might have to play c5 and
yeah actually this is smart buy over
from from our opponent because in some
variations of things divorce
nevertheless I think it was the night
5595
will go I beautify if I felt was
slightly less precise denied
it was 97 97 yeah maybe one good night
we need to doesn't do thing Queenie one
put the Queen on a five and developed a
bit I think you're supposed like ah you
know the culture in me tells me that the
night has to be only five because you
exert a lot of pressure against these
two pawns and playing b6 with our rooks
doubled on still Queen e1 e2
yeah well played like Quincy 1b should G
1 actually H 3 is hanging so we will
eventually have to play h3 h4 right
because we don't want to be blundering
that phone and also like I'm hinting no
not yet
you're screaming about b5 of me or you
know Hindi no no no no not be tree yeah
you don't have time let's wait for one
more move and then we'll go I kind of
want to wait for him to vacate they have
6 square so he doesn't have the
immediate night g44 net but then
actually I mean g4 that's we go for it
we're creating a weakness it's not he
will have to react if he takes we go
Bishop e2 and we've open the file
no g4 h 4 of course you played before I
think that's you know it's so for I
really want to play Knight b3 but you
don't put the bishop on a 2 first and
then you'll play Knight b3 because now
there might be some tactical issues like
93 another 3 is very strong yeah I was
kinda calculating the bishop has to be
only 2 in this position I think h4 was a
very large mistake mara yeah because it
makes us completely forget about the
King start and this is exactly what we
want to be doing here to just switch the
entirety of the game to the Queen side
and then we will be very comfortable
just kind of bring more vector well
supposed to be very comfortable yeah I
mean we're never entirely comfortable
well coffee is only it's waste so we
will but I for some mysterious reason
decided to ask for no coffee
mm-hm that was that was your choice of a
coffee yeah that my my my coffee choices
they want to change his mind he's mine
you're mine that's well it's been in my
hair talking I mean you know yeah
you have a very unenviable situation
right there yeah
a disembodied voice of Bensimon is a
scary thing to contend with but we're
doing well because now this night is
getting reroute it and funny enough we
might think of moves like rook c5 and
stuff yeah sure but like me typically it
shouldn't be possible but somehow with
the way it stands like like for now we
need to react wait Luke c5 I mean seven
we think then I know let's see it is not
I think I think this is quite strong
here actually because we will force him
to make some very uncomfortable this it
means the knight on c5 is yeah yeah
because like there's might even be some
tactics connected with the knight takes
a seeks and I think to be seven because
the whole edifice is about to crumble I
feel
look at me using long words yeah a lot
of look at how is Emilia words with them
long words well yeah that that's what I
thought we take only five here and how
do we win what does he do I guess he
takes with the Queen do we play queen g4
if he takes was the queen there was
there was an argument against it I mean
I don't quite remember what it was yeah
I thought there was but then now I can
spot it anymore I think we for might
surprising you'd be very strong because
we do have no this this one yeah we were
prepared for this right yet you know I
have a feeling that pretty much every
move wins now but there is a steep on
they take up taking upon us as important
as this can can never be a mistake
so we're playing a positional
masterpiece yeah we are playing a
positional masterpiece people on chat
doing vista gate who is the other random
guy sitting next to Peter Swiffer
come on yeah no close guess is so far
nobody knows it's none of the title
should be in a title somewhere isn't
Mira much lower rated yeah of course
he's how is this relevant do anything
why must he speaking so authoritative
Lee because that's that's the way I
speak but you didn't pay attention I was
insulted by great Peter Svidler and
couple of occasions that means I do know
something let's win on the spot maybe
not quite why I see takes yes and he
moves the key where to h8 Nikon d600
yeah right here you trade and fair
enough okay winning the game winning the
game takes precedence over positional
considerations and and this actually
runs yes yeah that was planned yeah I
did see I did see this one
all right so we actually even survived
the whole castle the opposite side
challenge which is and won nine yellow
points we are crushing it
crushing sit no no no no no no no what
did he do
I made a mistake you clicked I click the
thing yeah and then what I will probably
with apologies to our opponent Isis this
is not you've clicked every mail if
there's there's ice there's 126 people
in the list and I I'm Anna to miss click
yeah apologist to budge day but we're
not playing the same person for the
second game in a row so tell me tell me
opening choices uh once again let's try
it'll be fair we tried the opposite
castle thing with black yeah let's let's
do that so we can don't make stupid
minute we have to play then and I know
we tell key of some sort yeah yeah yeah
precisely so like yeah we can start with
g6 yeah let's trick him let's let's
pretty the way so that our King side
this week so he'll go for long constant
so we can castle normally because black
is not supposed to oh well we had to do
a petrol thing where you can ah yeah but
the is very much predicated on them
playing 593 si because otherwise you I
think you're in a tremendous amount of
trouble
with black it obviously is a lot more
challenging because you're in you know a
really not in control of what's
happening to you
do we play b6 here we probably do it
might actually even be the sort of the
correct approach even without the whole
the whole casting well because you don't
want to be allowing what I know
sometimes they do a six a phone they put
the night on CC yeah they're making uh
yeah that would be that would be the
other argument whoa that's uh let me
tell you what our opponent Kathleen
short in this case most likely after
before I think we actually have to start
preparing to Castle queenside yeah yeah
it'll be my let's just win something
quickly so that it's kind of cheating
but III endorse this yeah I think
probably without reading some material
in this game we are going to be in a lot
of trouble okay that's probably too much
we are we i if we've is it if we win
this much material I think we might be
oh you mean your trade them d2 up the
bishop yeah I don't think you know no
I'm not thinking only one I'm not taking
only one no one is stupid in this video
okay
spoiler spoilers
okay so now we have to prepare yeah I
think this is very important to play
five so maybe somehow somehow we don't
get completely steamrolled on the
queenside yeah what it's gonna be oh
yeah thank you so very much
let's get the knight on c5 yeah yeah
yeah I'm going 497 you are beautiful
beautiful piece yeah and now we can it
feels slightly unfair though because
we're like you're supposed to be on the
verge of losing for like then move
straight when you go for this challenge
and here it really doesn't feel like
we're gonna be losing yeah so let's play
then a few kind of normal ones
yeah we'll pull probably we can do the
reverse feminine brain I don't know why
I'm it's maybe time to start taking on
a4 or playing a5 or doing something but
you know it's you feel this kind of an
itch when the king is on CA they have
King BA the world like once again you
can always do this and this is silly in
there and stuff yeah it just doesn't
feel right until you get the King to a
proper square when should they all start
opening things up but how many like this
Bishop on b7 is a traitor right we could
we could actually probably win the
challenge of getting all of our pieces
on the dark squares if not for the note
for the bishop yeah yeah we could maybe
take on h3 oh yeah yeah I'm taking an h3
next move seriously yes yes and then I'm
taking a screenshot and then you go G
yeah you take an eager g5 yeah yeah yeah
all right okay once again kids do not
try this at home if you are piece up
just just win you know screenshot please
our opponent though was doing some
inappropriate things why he has the rook
the queen and the king on that's why we
are better he is not participating he's
not you say it's like we're somewhat
better yes yes somewhat better we were
fully winning we were more better when
we when we still had pieces but extra
pieces in particular but screenshot yeah
like who says no to a screenshot like
this looks like we can get the triple
Queen t8 yeah 28 g8 h7 there might be
797 eyes yeah like my boys let's
actually start winning this game maybe
for a change
yeah stop moving around the other for a
bit like seriously you don't like I
think Queen c5 even Queen c5 is good but
like yeah in something this particular
in the case like quick Quincey 596 don't
get another pawn yeah don't don't
disagree yeah just didn't like the idea
of offering offering trades when we
don't need to offer trades but yeah now
back to c5 but it was there already like
I want it on the news so you want to
yeah I'm doing the the shuffle yeah no
check we to know again I know how we are
never wait but but we have to do it in
the proper way
without anything coming on a white
square well you can we manage I know now
we know now we can manage so we haven't
I didn't have to play 97 so something
was on the light so Erica likewise I
mean that that's why the night is
imperfect yeah you cannot keep it only
the same squares for okay enough enough
of the memeing thing yeah let's play a
couple of the dilly dallying yeah let me
just find
something where can you turn them on
leeches yeah move suppose you choose the
you choose the opening the opening night
f6 yeah and then shall we play the Benko
the weird Bank oh yes c5
what's the non the weird well all of
them weird but this one is particularly
we are b5 ok a 6 ok so far yeah now I
don't know he was supposed to take and
then what were 6 what are the e6 yeah
all night takes before that it's not
it's not how you're supposed to hang on
problem is I don't really know the Banco
theory like this shouldn't be good for
white but why exactly it how do I know
yeah this is this is I mean kind of hard
to stop memeing once you've stopped yeah
yeah it's a it's an ongoing process but
94 yeah I'm actually very seriously
maybe maybe it's yeah maybe it's not
just a me move maybe it's just get rid
of the bishop on c1 because I think we
should do - that's like Quincy to
capture Bishop d2 if this works for him
I am then it might be decent yeah that
is there is a problem we go Queen 84 23
d6 I guess and we claim we still have
conversations read this way we take yeah
we might have to play the dreaded
endgame again
but that's a cool one yeah despite being
a pawn down I think you're quite happy
here with black you have tremendous
compensation but yeah 95 93 a B I think
they normally play with the intention of
playing these really crazy lines
starting with E for before might be fine
right yeah and that that is yet another
bit of theory I have absolutely zero
idea about them I think the five is not
really supposed to be okay finally
please play the bone cloud in caps
letters bond claw yeah we could we could
maybe do one
close isn't it the opening you really
have to know your theory one pretty much
yeah I think I suspect I mean when you
start like like I used to start my white
games 93g 3 Bishop g2 that's it's like
it does give you a room for flexibility
yeah I had I had a period of playing
either 33 Bishop g2 against anything as
well so what's the correct way of
proceeding here like g6 of 5 or
something that's what I thought
yeah like rook a4 but before Ruby one is
slightly awkward as a reply but no I
said yeah counseled kinda need it and
then we proceed accordingly to what he
does now I I'm guessing these on yeah
you're absolutely right okay yeah now
okay for is just very concretely I can I
got got scared of Bishop III for some
reason but and you even do this you
don't Yeah right
see - ok 3 and after night night night
eggs and then night before next before
very next myth seriously now we're kind
of firmly in control
yeah that that's how like those are the
positions that make Benko players
happens yeah the success rate of the
Queen's you're speculating on not
winning the pole immediately because you
don't want to have an equal material in
banker I should be one with
significantly say - maybe and okay
forget it okay yeah like I'm not in time
maybe I am in time because I like it's
very important for me to lend the knight
on c4 here and ninety three immediately
runs in through k1 and I have no trade
some very nice pieces and this way I
want to play Knight e3 next move and if
he goes okay bond I have 90 or as a fly
he worried yeah and there was my that
was my clever idea here I don't know how
clever it actually is but there was why
we are getting to this awkward stage of
the game where we can we will actually
have to think or not really probably not
everyone was a very large mistake
because yeah this allows this allows my
little champion
but yeah I think let's say if in this
position he just goes King g3 King D
forces me to play c4 check and then goes
to maybe III I'm not even sure how much
better I'm probably better but I guess
better might be five rook a maybe some
might be fine yeah so far
generally a some automatic banker game
but we were a bit helped by by our
opponent most apiece chrome field
signatures Whitlock and we can we do
this with white pieces now how about
bond cloud instead but like I don't know
the rules of the bond club am I allowed
not to blunder the e4 pawn for instance
how do you play it against the LAN
before maybe maybe not against 20 to 21
anyway because it feels like whenever
this this idea gets floated I feel like
I'm like severely disrespecting my
opponent and it doesn't come it doesn't
come very naturally what did you do to
opposition well I gained some space in
the center i okay
why are you like what what okay look I
have more space yes space all this space
speaking of monster pieces yes we what
about them attack the king will we will
attempt to attack the king yeah in
particular here like I want to play c4
for some reason it might not even be a
bad move
yeah I should be a good move do we care
if it's a yeah I don't think like why
why was that even a consideration
yeah but suddenly I have like I have no
idea why I believe that man I do not
know wait the plan was to go see g5 but
now I realized that takes d4 is a reply
that exists which kind of undermines my
yeah I mean I mean misses the planner I
thought thought to be head that they
gonna default oh I'm trying to channel
my inner Tricia but my inner critic is
these days very very dormant what what
was the problem seated yeah okay
whatever she did for 9594 how do we
proceed three yeah thanks Bishop c4 yeah
yeah that's not impossible but I think I
think this is how Sasha would have
played this nothing on I need to not
Blundell e5 pawn them okay speaking of I
was responsible to be quiet and read the
charts right so I'm certainly abusing my
position here is what chat tells you
what I'm telling myself and gets Tommy
did there are questions like who's
better between the two of us and then
what though it precisely that's so
that's the most relevant question yeah
we are talking the board games that's
better do we play a three here do we get
the Bishop over to g3 first as well my
question for you to go to but also like
it's somebody at some point we go a
three before almost a sweet victory
it's it's a nice prophylactic move and
also we do at some point start opening
the queenside up so I think it's but
then again like I want by night on this
square and in that respect I think
starting with this before was much
stronger because the flea you should
play 96 care if he doesn't play 96 here
I will play why don't you tell our
opponent what he has to do because I'm
quitting stupid like what's our next
move g3 h4 I guess but yeah I don't
think I played this correctly I think
this ship had to be on g3 a long time
ago to make our transfer of the over the
night towards the e4 square a lot faster
we're still reasonably in control here I
think because once we connect the night
this point only five is very safe and
this this whole group of pieces black
has in the center does very little I'm
guessing we are getting outplayed that's
the feeling but yeah I mean I should if
I should have done better a bit earlier
and this before you were talking about
porn in some way yeah but we don't care
like we need to start opening things up
and then like pretend it's gonna work I
don't think it's even necessarily well
how about h4 that's why I played u3 but
I don't want a lot of pics of 395 I need
to have the night sky brilliant yeah but
look of seven rotate your fate I guess
is what I would have done in this
position if I were playing black this is
yet to put the bishop on see this is
quite sensible but it's I think I think
now we start yeah we've now we start
with no longer wait for anything and
hope for the it for it to work in some
way yeah
Knight of what do we do now do you ever
play b5 I mean there's definitely
positional positional arguments for
playing b5 but I've wanted to take on c5
and play 94 I'm trying to calculate if
it's possible at all doesn't seem to be
possible just yet we could go Bishop b2
you go Ruby 1 I mean I don't really
understand what wait what does he do if
you don't just play b5 and then put the
push the NBA Bishop c8 the moment you
plays b6 we play a 5 minute okay it's
just waiting everyone is a good move
because I mean it makes all of our BC 5
ideas slightly stronger and also I want
to ask our opponent like why did you
play 98 97 are you really planning to
195 here which seemingly helps us great
yeah because take stakes 94 and 96 check
is just
crushingly strong and reply be and after
b6 I've like I'm becoming sorely tempted
here to do what to take and go 94 and
wonder a beautiful pony let's go age for
first I mean now actually h5 is a very
large threat so this is what he meant
but what sir yeah yeah what's the reply
to h5 am i blundering some beautiful
combination it's like magic
five I guess unless you want something
like real beauty which I guess he wants
95 and that might even be puff puff
Diesel's
happening what's my g5 okay we trade
well even a blow should take only what
he feeds and then what mission like 94 I
still want to do this yes I'm a boring
person
look yeah look at him
I'm greedy I'm greedy person not nautics
unknown green I'm a very but you are
hungry D I mean if it's like which is
right the opposite to greedy
why did I plunder the pollen III though
nobody knows because you you're planning
to win I just I just forgot they can see
five take on h7 will have a beautiful
postpone yeah that's true I mean we're
still doing fine but that was a mistake
yeah I just didn't I didn't see Bishop
takes a three existed azimuth we did not
need so she's six week which is not any
to allow this yeah and I always trade
yeah we are boring yeah we're sighs now
we just we were just win this endgame
the a pawn alone does not vary much him
at some point our guys will be quite
they are quite a few white numerous you
know let's know that was I mean I was
also fine I mean there was there was no
page six years already those well at
some point we will have to take care of
this a a dude yeah like that I mean
there's just too many enemy as my friend
and colleague young Gustafson would say
in a situation like this why did I
blunder h7 I don't know give you a
constantly blundering f7 like after f5
of to them and I continue blundering it
yeah yeah just move your King away
let's stop plundering age seven men
that's because you you're moving the
wrong poem the G poem should have been
and you don't care about this yet you
could keep the rook as well for uh yeah
now we are waiting Bishop g6 right
six yeah we thank and we take and we
take a - if it's yeah oshiro cash one
check is even stronger but yeah there
was there was a horribly miss played in
game also g3 is actually kind of
annoying now move the Jeep on dude why
do you keep moving the other pieces I
mean G v g6 what's why you why are you
criticizing my you know I I have such a
beautiful construction on the board
right now like nothing will agree stop
sniping me from the sidelines that's
harsh but yeah that was we had an
absolutely gorgeous position and then I
started playing it which is which is
often what happens like somewhere around
here I think there were no wrong choices
and I still managed to find some or
maybe or maybe somewhere around here
that was there was a new mirror of
course was absolutely correct not taking
on g6 like there was done for stylistic
reasons and they are was I do like JG
Bishop d2 and Bishop d2 is Jewish before
like for some reason I can't actually
move pre-intermediate that's sufficient
so I suspect we cannot take with the
bishop on D - yes - and and obviously
the like in this position there I think
you've done very well and then over here
this actually nothing I look at it it's
a G might not be a mistake because if we
take with this rock I give up only fire
let me let me come up with the mission I
mean if I'm a lot BC 5 mm maybe we see 5
yeah maybe it's stupid ok whatever no
I'm not sure I think it might be my
request Iran I even considered it for a
second but I thought why not HT 6
because I thought in this position the
bishop has to retreat along this
diagonal and then we win in like 10
different ways anyway and now let's go
back enough about this let's play some
more
some more chests click on analysis board
in computer will tell you we all need
the computer
yeah that's a let's play ok let's play
decent oh no wait wait on a screen
sure grunt chest or London the finals
starts tomorrow once again you'll be
commentating I will become enticing as
will you and we have a team scandal but
do we even remember any of this candy
theory yes you develop the pieces left
to right and then you check make him
somewhere Knight f3 yes should G for
them g4 okay I used to know this idea
but III no longer really remember
anything at all like Bishop b4 is and
also and also I think we should Bishop
c4 was yeah this is not how you this is
not how you do this way if you're
supposed to do this you're not supposed
to do it with ambitious I need to have
94 as a move here seriously yeah what
something just play something and stop
saying words is what you're trying I
know should be too yeah okay we can do I
know we can't do the thing the cousin
thing anymore because Gosling short will
be I mean we're doing okay but some
fairly sure this is this is not how
you're supposed to be playing this
opening he takes takes place Queen b6
and it's a little bit awkward because if
I Castle queenside he goes 95 and I'm
not sure I have a very comfortable reply
I don't know which takes Bishop a to you
know like why it been the porn yeah
I'm peeing my porn or something I better
be considering to be honest um I'm not
sure I don't think we're prepared for
that I guess he takes on c3 and goes
Queen b5 now that would be a that would
be an endgame yeah but that would be a
decent end game for black from from
where I'm sitting but it will be an
ending
yeah there's paid to me yeah well the
Bishop III had other issues I I don't
know which which square was the proper
square there also I really don't know
what our opponent is meanwhile God while
you're playing chess people ask how will
I find the child
yeah chat this chat is really nice for
me they're so so kind to us and where's
your selection that that's a nice
question yes yes yes there is uh having
having you know enjoying life life what
are we supposed to do here they're like
honest honest question teach the guy an
endgame lesson that would be my guess
okay why would you think because how do
we get to an end game without taking our
yeah right so you mean he would not take
himself no I think he just keeps it
there and goes I don't know 95 48 or
whatever I think we're actually slightly
worse area now we'll be teach the
endgame lesson yeah this looks like yeah
not very happy but that's okay oh maybe
I should have played at four cuz I don't
want to I don't want to allow life now
you play it for all day every day yeah
yeah and then I go h4 h5 Andrew yeah I
don't like no seriously cost Castle yeah
I think I think I think the king should
have been the king should have been
somewhere around seven that's a clever
move though though we give him the
bishop on she want I think the answer is
well we didn't no no no because they for
porn he goes knight c6 and then we have
more tactical issues let's know this
actually blunders 93 don't touch what
she put this I mean it's good like this
only one actually isn't isn't good at
all like the night - yeah we have
terrible that's yeah yeah yeah yeah can
we do this without losing because I
would like to okay
we are less than one minute yeah that's
fair because we've straightened out our
position a little bit here does loop the
f12 with tree okay maybe I wanted to go
a four but yeah making sure we don't
right yeah I don't know five and then
what take was the point yeah i see i
wanna i want to remind if he has some
potential as well yeah that's not the
position but the bishop thing is the
actual thing i don't know why i mean
that the like the decisive factor will
be that we're behind on a clock i'm
pretty sure but yeah but I think that
the bishops are like a thing in most
cases and this is no not I do don't see
to these it's not great but he Luke h8 I
think was slightly oblivious and you
know okay
my gosh five kind of we need to make
sure we don't blunder a rook there okay
we're not blundering a rope here
[Music]
yeah I'm not playing this well but I'm
kind of panicking because we're very
short on time here
this is the best position we had all
game but it doesn't really matter a
great deal whoa now it does it's
actually kind of winning three six yep
yeah even converted brilliant
hooray so what do with other any
suggestions in chat as to what we should
be doing I should be talking less apart
apart from it I don't I don't condone
that I want yeah Ben tells us that
rather tells me that we have to remind
the about the next show well yeah we
will we will continue doing this for
maybe one or two more games and then and
then there will be a short break and
then if Kenny will will do another one
of these with Al mirror in a different
language
a beautiful I'm not sure or maybe it may
be in the same language human yeah yeah
will do we'll try to do in English me
yeah no as good as you are I have no
idea why I'm playing the cattle and all
of a sudden I thought you were wanting
to go G for it to be honest I mean the
way you yeah yeah no I'm not a Catalan
player I I really don't know why this is
on the board right now when tonight went
to see treatment no it's it's beautiful
yeah now that we have not been here my
53 and 94 tremendous position we are
enjoying life once again or at least
making a brave face of it
what would you look like out of three
it's like like that tree leads you to
kind of decent names of where you're
going forever
very good name so yeah I agree so you
want to take with the video well fair
point and we can do the castle thing
again
yeah I wanna play in that h3 though I
think he'll play d6 and not a lot I'll
probably play D 3 d 6e I'm very sad
about this as I wanna I really want to
do castle Thing Thing yes it's for yeah
edge for this actually makes sense but
97 f6 like I don't want to ruin our
position too much maybe maybe we're not
97 you're on time night h3 he cannot
take then Knight f6 Knight the four
maybe it's not that terrible but it
takes days goes Queenie for I'm not sure
it's great mmm might be Manas Lee yeah
honestly I'm not sure it's great
we're one move away from lending it on
the beautiful beautiful f4 square but
this time this time another man be
scared he's going to take it or bishops
on he might have to but we're not that
we are in the mirror I mean we take he
was night before we go back and I don't
think he's in time to push the
sixty-five way and as long as ya trying
to interrupt me to talk over you but how
do you prove that the bishop is stronger
than the night for an English speaker I
mean it's very common and it's very
well-liked pronounced in Russian but
it's just like the names of the base the
one is the horse the other one over the
airship bishop the bishop has you know
access to divine powers the one party it
has access to thirty two squares only so
it's pretty limited well they're talking
about the the names of the pieces right
so okay and then the knight without
without the blessing of the bishop the
knight can't actually doesn't have
divine shield then it doesn't have
divine shield and it doesn't really have
you know nothing they need to but we
push the night away not to allow d65 so
easily for for our point yeah we will
not castle long in this yeah we're not
not anymore
yeah we're not casting along in this
game we're casting short then the
position of the 94 is quite playable for
black actually because it's it's gonna
be a bit of a hassle to get it get it
away from this square could just be a
bit more than quite playable I don't
think we're Wars but I I don't think
we're like with the pollen H do we would
have the option of playing at four and
then three with the Polish forum I lost
a lot less confident that's any good
okay so they'll be yeah you're right
they'll be quite tough too
yeah III in the proper way so I think my
mistake was maybe I needed to play three
somewhere here before this this became a
subject we are too may have discussion
and be five I'm quite happy to see
first of all III now winds are born
which is an improvement on on previous
case I think seriously yeah I think we
have to but that will have to be getting
netting truck mated no I don't think
we're using checkmated I think we're
like we're good idea I think we have
enough defensive resources there it's a
bit of a boring move something like see
before it was more adventurous but yeah
but I think we're follow exactly we are
not getting checkmate how like what's
the mechanism for us to get checkmate
yeah like a bigger question I'm scared
he has keys pieces around like I mean I
leave scared but that doesn't mean I'm
not I'm not a pawn up here
[Music]
Peter part from groffle twitch opening
do you consider yourself as specialist
well probably the the rural office with
both colors will be my do we take the
rock the probably thumb and then we drop
them the bottom beat so that's not great
let's go II thought we might take the
rook after g4 but even that is not
strictly speaking force through g3 my
beer kind of me likey yeah I think it
goes back and you've been that way then
we consider our options yeah that's
that's the way to build a thing like p3
maybe you yeah Quincy to might be moved
as well also we will just flag him and
stop you know pretending we're playing a
chess game it was never a point to play
proper chess f3 and i36
yeah they always start having issues we
actually do have issues already yeah
objectively this position is still quite
difficult to play I think you we will
need to we would need to be quite
careful that's the trick you're doing I
wanted to do this but now I realize
Queen of sixes and if see I'm going I've
miss played this horribly you go back to
E - yeah but then d3 is a move and then
you go - you want well then I go to u1
and I pretend this this is all going
according to plan when it's quite
clearly isn't time so take 84 let's play
for the move that deserve to be played
like ages again that's true yeah let's
stabilize yeah this is a born it will be
a stabilizing no but this is this has to
be good enough this fester we're gonna
fall so here's 5 seconds but even
objective no I think this is winnings
actually treat what do we think like if
everything disappears on the other side
of the board two against three against
two it's a draw it's probably a Troy
it's probably even a comfortable draw
those thingies are unlikely to disappear
right be careful with Lucas tree because
GE I don't want to largely find it's
just in a corner somewhere
whoops almost wandered up broke there
yeah
it should have been a mistake not that
easy no it's not trivial but it's still
the same piece yeah yeah it's still a
lot easier to play with the rooks I feel
because maybe that's fine maybe that's
not sure oh yeah i blundered finished
six check there your vectors to know
that h2 that was yeah me naming the
squares incorrectly right what am i what
are we doing here what are we doing I
mean I want to play before but I have a
feeling that actually allows a perpetual
and allowing I maybe it doesn't but it
drops the porn anyway I played myself
into like an unbelievable amount of
technical issues here your opponent
offers a draw that would destroy our
hundred percent right now or the show
that's not happening but yeah yeah I
think the sequence of moves was ready no
we're not doing this we're not doing
this in any way correctly of course yeah
this is kind of really horrible
conversion technique you know it's
shameful to even call this a conversion
technique it's not the technique
basically yeah g4 yeah let's lose this
one you know it's let's lose this game
somehow I don't think I don't think
we're losing this game now I think we're
still okay unless King H yeah but then
like now we start pushing the beep on
and get it all the way to like be
careful the guy wanted to checkmate us
I'm aware that wasn't very nice of him
the b-pawn have no no other choice right
or you found some mechanism Bob - I
check on G 600 G 1 maybe index H 4
though I
I wanted to do this for whatever reason
right and then this yeah they're on us
and Iran and now we run yeah but that's
a shameful game really yeah that that
really isn't how you how you play these
types :
oh he's much higher rated role should
have been yeah we said we should be
honored by the draw for there why did I
play good god lucky six was just winning
on the spot and Irish and now it's an
actual draw again
well we win some rating points which is
very upsetting did i blunder a ruk oh
you could i didn't just yeah you almost
and we might be winning now as we might
be giving mate king g5 whoa whoa whoa
physics hanging go be seven funny yeah
this is a check that's how Peter wins
games and now I think this is winning
that's like he lets not blunder kinesics
maybe yeah yeah this is this is one for
the ages obviously like so horrible is
it legal to challenge us with
anti-choice or Backhouse you don't think
so no I
moreover the barely we're barely
handling the the game we are
quote-unquote experts and and you know
yeah the being requests are for 960 but
if I if I spot one we will play one I
have absolutely nothing there will be
the be fair I believe oh yeah there some
there are some 960 challenges let's play
let's play one no idea to plate okay so
and now we have to thank for a bit
because like you you actually are
supposed to think about the starting
position I think the way to develop here
appears to be some kind of committee
of c4 and d4 and you want to get the
Queen in play as early as possible in
this types of you know how to play it
right I mean you've been playing those
things
yes e4 Knight b6 my baby is annoying
because no but probably not
and the the way to reply to these things
I mean I over the course of my once
again quote-unquote 960 career I've
tried g3
I've tried staying away from staying
away from symmetry more than months with
black and that normally leads to really
horrendous results so I think our
opponent was perfectly justified and
trying to play symmetrically and what
I'm dying to doing here like I'm I was
very worried there for a second that he
could play d5 with the idea of if I take
playing c4
mmm-hmm that could have been annoying
but I don't know here I'm one move away
from establishing you know an actual
merits a bind with you know good pieces
remaining put the Queen on h1 good
pieces remaining with you I mean if he
was on c8 I wouldn't be so happy but
with the Queen on h8 like I think we're
okay here we kind of really we reinforce
this we go 90 stores a Queenie five
attacks the phone h2 now that's kind of
funny know that we can we potentially
don't care yeah that's true
the moment he takes we still have to
catch one yeah yeah that's right so
which side do we castle on and there's
some argument for trying to Castle
queenside here like play b3 which be
three Bishop I think I'm making these
moves anyway like b3m Bishop III feels
like they they will be moves I will be
making against most things just to make
sure I don't blunder something suddenly
Quinn g'wan but once again a queen G 1 F
2 and then castle Queen King side maybe
but you have to pay attention so that
you don't block you can go to in g1 yeah
I thought yeah even if they immediately
knew I was also sensible but I like I
like establishing this this setup and
this is a very good Marisa type move
because the phone belongs on h4 in many
these positions I think against age five
in particular castling queenside becomes
a lot more attractive like bishops you
do and just castle and go wait a second
depends really like if you can't like
when f2 next move I would still consider
Gosling short even with the Polish four
yeah if he goes H four we can't Blake we
never like let's say he makes a move we
play Queen F - he plays h4 then we or
just go H for ourselves now how do we
make progress then like then like I we
don't need to we have more space let's
start with this yeah let's start with
this and then we will consider our
options yeah we definitely do have more
space but like castle short he goes h4
how do we ever make anything happen
anywhere on the board
it's my question let's find out what
well what why didn't it allow me to
Castle you can't Castle I don't know I
didn't know how to castle did I actually
has castle then we cannot this is
confusing bag okay let's try to go for
lone Castle which is obviously not the
great move I think I think this might be
some kind of a some kind of what's it
called custom challenge where he can
castle and we can't which is one more
time one more time vase the king from e1
yeah clearly put it on now no I'm pretty
sure we got we got swindle okay h4 g3
we'll castle you know we'll castle
somehow it's been done to me one song
you have to just know what the rook did
the what you have to hover over the rook
so you probably have to put it on f1
okay the king that's so that's so know
that we are calling sure that's a reach
for put the king on the roof yes okay
chat is very helpful I even played some
960 on me chest only chest and I'm
pretty sure that's not how it used to
work
that's the biggest challenging yes no
but like I'm not kidding this this has
been done to me once on chess 24 during
a banter session somebody created a
custom challenge where I play the naps
with as many restrictions yeah I played
an absolutely normal game for a for a
while it it's actually true yeah and and
then I tried cussing because like my as
usual my strategy my strategy was kind
of predicated on being able to castle at
some point in the game and it just
wouldn't let me
and yeah that became that became a
problem very quickly so what we have now
here is sort of a decent Marazzi or no
this is a good position now because now
we have the four or five maybe six that
might be 796 was the plan and before
allowing the yeah I'm not allowing not
allowing me that's boring but it wins so
like once again it's a study stickers we
probably do yeah I think we don't think
we do I mean it's it's not the most
exciting way of winning the position
here but like and we we got a frowny
face in chat because I think he did not
see Bishop g5 this was not a sacrifice I
can understand the frowny that the
frowny face
look everyone is not a great move
because now after Queen f6 I yeah and f6
is not a graph for f4 yeah okay okay
get rid of the [ __ ] please one time
okay okay one time so now that we know
our position is better in every single
aspect of the game that is true that is
not that he ever was I mean it probably
was better no I mean let's be honest
probably 96 was better but it looks like
this is also perfectly serviceable for
sure mmm so can we inquire of mr. simon
as to what the cutoff point is because I
don't want to encroach on on the next
show it's still there's still a game
going on come on come on that's for
Emily that's horribly disrespectful for
our bond and we can play one more okay
that's what we told okay
what's the score the score is a hundred
percent 100 percent and how come we are
still not 25 or whatever it was first of
all we're playing various game modes and
secondly we started off from a somewhat
low low starting point yeah okay one
more we're being told and then there are
we I will vacate the premises and I
almost like this looked like dice and
then I realized it's not dice it's time
and if this was if this if this was dice
I would be playing dice right now for
sure but it's not just a sec let me just
before the last game of the day I want
to find I want to find somebody who can
destroy our hundred percent record 2283
there was something yes about the 2301
that sounds scary yeah that's that's
probably bad news for us the bad news
bad news bears what do we play that's an
11th game there then all up bad news
bears
that's a very very solid play
yes I don't know I play 97 here but it's
not a mistake
it kind of is aimed specifically at
making the c4 line slightly less
attractive for white but I mean they're
still perfectly playable of course so
you do not want the symmetrical grown
fruit that's an ICC can take that like
yeah I'm not doing this right you're a
group of players show us yeah but yeah
gee is this is this is really not good
at all I mean it's fine but it's not
what I wanted I wanted something I mean
Knight takes e4 here is like instantly
ever so slightly better for white
without any risk for the rest of the
game so pretty sure it is yeah and then
we play for Bishop a5 Queen b6 I mean
we're fine
it's not horrible but it's not what I
wanted I wanted a slightly more they
fight a slightly more fighting position
sure it's fine white sometimes still get
some pressure in positions like this or
in general gets yeah it very much
depends on depends on the outcome of the
next few next few moves because like
Queen b6 and even a 5 a 4 immediately I
mean and and the thing is you at some
point I think need to trade the white
square or the light squared bishop scare
for white but not everybody likes that
idea and yes mystery and this one we are
really happy with yeah this is I don't
think this is the right structure to to
be destroying your your pawns
okay sometimes they do this yeah yeah
like if you if you still have a light
mm-hmm the other night it goes 3/5 and
it's extremely annoying if I've or
sometimes they've been seen yet I even
get its but with only the two bishops
left on the board this is on for a week
and
you know a lot less for free
unbelievably comfortable structure for
black for really for nothing and yeah
there is the adage for h5 play but it's
just sort of never fast enough there's
there's never enough time laundry Angela
I have blundered upon but I don't really
mind I'm scared I don't think it's a
blunder necessarily
I think we can probably even take
because the Queen might be getting
caught there but you know I can't car
yeah I think we can yeah we can take on
define I forgot he can take on define
that's a miss play and they couldn t
five on what and I'll take on be seven
that's that's my point this is this is
what I missed
I mean we're still perfectly fine there
but it's it's clearly not how I should
have been playing this position and now
I think we just go for we just go for
the end game and game is just very very
big define why would you do this only
mean might be seven or C seven sorry
yeah can be five yeah let's stop giving
him this trade because it makes his life
easier to to get that trade in be three
I guess yeah and this is where you start
seeing what happens to this structure
when when you don't actually generate
any we managed to plate not in the most
comfortable way yeah and I wasn't I
wasn't doing the shredder I really
really love to have H 5 H 5 there is
some yeah we have a visitor there's some
Mira trying to some trying to some you
don't have the mic you know there's no
matter what do you say I'm here there is
some weirdness going on as you know can
be relied that's for pumping you me okay
coming up in rematch offer like always
apologist store opponent but there will
not be a rematch because as you can see
we are being we're being invaded and I
think that's that's my cue to to wave at
you in a vaguely friendly manner and go
somewhere else and let the the beautiful
people do do the thing that they do yeah
precisely and yes if and I suspect
there'll be a lot of people in a child
who will
they've been with us only to listen to
me to Switzerland they're not planning
to join for a next show there will be a
big no-no for them it's a reminder that
tomorrow's gonna be another piece
witless show and and when the rest of
the team sir London classics or which is
the final of brunches tour starts
tomorrow
once again ten minutes to ten local
times includes ten minutes to 4:00 p.m.
in London yep and no beat yeah that that
should be a lot of fun very very nice
field watching Magnus always always a
pleasure and yeah hope you tune in
tomorrow but for now there will be a
slight break whilst we get you know on
miked and then allomere I get smacked in
and all of that good good things and
more more play the people more play the
people and I suspect I'll be allowed to
make a few moves you probably you
probably will be a lot to lose it to
make a few moves and I can have my phone
back and yeah and I can watch glory play
Jack Attack unimpeded thanks for
watching and stay tuned for the second
part of the thing
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you
you